>> Qi Qiu: Okay, so I am
literally in the spot.
Okay, this is the first
experience for us to host
such an event here in
the Asian Reading Room.
So my name is Qi Qiu,
Head of Scholarly Services
at the Asian Reading Room.
So on behalf of the Asian
Division, I welcome you
to this afternoon's event
and to our reading room.
I especially appreciate your
coming out this afternoon
on such a, you know,
snowy, rainy day.
It's not the best day but we
do appreciate your efforts.
So for this afternoon's program,
after my welcome remarks,
Dr. Jonathan Loar, who is
our South Asian librarian,
he will give an introduction
of our South Asian collection
and will also introduce our
speaker, Dr. Richard Solomon
from the University
of Washington.
So, as you have already seen,
this is a beautiful
reading room.
And if you haven't had a
chance to know more about it,
here are some highlights of
our facilities and services.
I know many of you.
I see some familiar faces.
Some of you are very
familiar with our services.
So pardon me for the repetition.
I will just take a few minutes.
So this reading room is home
to multilanguage reference
materials on Asian studies.
It is also where users
can access both physical
and digital materials
in Asian language
and get research assistance
from our reference specialists.
We started collecting Asian
language materials as early
as the late 19th century.
And today, the collections
have grown to represent one
of the most comprehensive
collections of Asian studies
in the world, that is more than
four million physical items
and numerous digital resources.
These items are in
over 190 languages
and include most subject fields
covering in the area ranging
from the South Asian
subcontinent
and Southeast Asia to East Asia.
So our reading room, the Asian
Reading Room opens Monday
to Friday from 8:30 to 5:00
p.m. Any users 16 years old
or older can come to use
the library reading rooms.
All you need to do is
to bring a photo ID
and get a reader registration
card, which is also located
on the first floor of
the Jefferson Building.
Of course, it's always a good
idea to check out our website
and library catalogue before
you come to the library
so that you can find the
materials that you are looking
for and make better uses of
your time in the library.
On our website, you can use a
link marked "Ask a Librarian"
to ask research questions,
to request materials
and to make appointments with
librarians to use rare items.
So "Ask a Librarian"
is an important phrase
for you to remember.
It is actually the
tour to find answers
to almost all of your inquiries.
Also on the website,
you can find information
on our collections,
databases, digital collections,
research guides, and blogs.
And yes, we do have social
medial representations.
We have blogs and we have
a Facebook page of all
of the international
collections in our library.
So since Florence
Tan Moeson Fellowship
for this year just opened,
I would like to raise your
attention to this fellowship
that funds researchers to come
to our reading room
to conduct research.
You can check out the
application information
on our website or on
our Facebook page.
The deadline for application
is the end of January.
So we would encourage you
to spread words among
your colleagues, friends,
and students who are
interested in coming out to DC
and to use our collection
materials
for their research projects.
So with that, I will hand
it over to Jonathan Loar
for a brief introduction of
our Southeast Asian collection.
Thank you.
>> Jonathan Loar:
Welcome everybody.
Welcome to the Asian Reading
Room of the Library of Congress.
My name is Jonathan Loar and
I'm the reference librarian
for the South Asian collection,
which contains materials
for Bangladesh, Bhutan,
India, Nepal, Pakistan,
Sri Lanka, and the Maldives.
So before we get started, I
just wanted to give a very,
very brief overview of our
South Asian collection,
which contains approximately
330,000 monographic volumes,
more than 1000 journals, and
over 68,000 titles on microform
in over 100 languages of
the South Asian region.
So that means we have
substantial holdings in Hindi,
Urdu, Tamil, Telugu, Malayalam,
Bengali, Gujarati, Punjabi,
Sanskrit, Pali, Prakrit
and many other languages.
Most of this acquisition comes
from the library's
two overseas offices,
one in New Delhi
established in 1962 and one
in Islamabad established
in 1965.
On the countertops here
in the reading room,
you'll see some samples
from our collections,
books about Buddhism in general
and about the ancient region
of Gandhara, in particular,
both in English
and also in Asian languages.
We invite everyone to come
and spend some time here
with our collections in
the Asian Reading Room.
And as Dr. Qiu just said,
if you have a question
about our collections, we have
our "Ask a Librarian" service
to answer anything pertaining
to your research or
general curiosity.
I would also like to
remind everyone here today
that today's program
will be recorded
and later released as a webcast.
So please turn off or
silence your mobile phones
and other devices and also
place hold your questions
until the end.
And please be advised that any
questions you may ask during the
Q&A will be recorded and the act
of asking a question constitutes
permission for us to record
and broadcast later as
part of our webcast.
For South Asia at the
Library of Congress,
I believe you could
call the subject
of today's lecture
a top treasure,
namely the birch bark scrolls
from the ancient Buddhist
region of Gandhara.
And to get to know
this treasure,
there is no better resource
than the experts on the history,
language and culture out of
which this manuscript
came to be.
Dr. Richard Solomon is
emeritus professor of Sanskrit
and Buddhist studies
at the University
of Washington in Seattle.
In addition to being the
director of the British library
and University of Washington's
early Buddhist Manuscript
Project, he is the author
of many publications
on early Buddhism, many of
which are on display here
at the Asian Reading Room today.
His most recent book, his
fourth on Gandhara manuscripts,
is titled "Buddhist
Literature of Ancient Gandhara:
An Introduction with
Selected Translations."
Translation number
eight in this book is
"The Many Buddhas Sutra,"
which is the scroll here
at the Library of Congress.
And now for more on this scroll,
I'd like to welcome
Dr. Richard Solomon.
[ Applause ]
>> Richard Solomon:
Can you hear me okay?
Is the microphone on?
I don't have a good
projecting voice.
So I want to be sure
you all can hear.
So first of all, thank
you, thanks to John
for the very nice introduction.
Second, I want to thank
you all for being here.
When I saw the weather this
afternoon, I had the concern
that I was going
to just be speaking
to an empty room this
evening but I see
that you've all braved the nasty
weather to come and I thank you
for that and I will try to
make it worth the effort.
So I'm going to start my
presentation with a description
of the physical characteristics
of the manuscript.
Contents and significance
will come later.
So the manuscript is called,
as you see here -- Next slide.
The title of the manuscript
or, to be accurate,
the title which I attribute
to the manuscript is
"The Many Buddhas Sutra,"
which is my translation
of the conjectural
title, original title.
It's not actually there on the
manuscript, "Bahubuddha-sutra."
Please note the asterisk.
Scholarly convention means that
that's a reconstructed title.
I didn't make it up totally.
I borrowed it from a related
and somewhat similar text
which exists in Sanskrit
as part of the Mahavastu.
So it's a conjectural
but pretty likely title.
The actual title of the
manuscript would have been
on some of the part that's
incomplete, that's missing.
So that's why I have
a hypothetical title.
And I'll show you the details
of that a little later.
First, briefly, the big picture.
This is one of several
hundred manuscripts discovered
within the last 20 years from
the ancient region of Gandhara.
And I'll show a map later
if you're not familiar
with Gandhara and where it is.
I'll get back to that.
But we now know of several
hundred manuscripts,
almost all of them like this
one, a birch bark scroll
and written in the
Gandhari language,
which I'll describe a
little bit later on,
and in the Kharosthi script,
which you'll also see
some illustrations of.
And these manuscripts date
between the first century BC
and the third century AD.
So they are clearly
the oldest manuscripts
of any manifestation
of Buddhism.
And they're also the oldest
South Asian manuscripts
in existence.
So here, you see the scroll as
it was delivered to the library.
The main piece is at the bottom,
rolled up piece of birch bark,
and the piece on top is actually
would've been an adjoining piece
but it had already broken off.
You might notice, I
don't know if you can see
from where you're sitting but
the two look quite different
and the reason is that they're
in a different handwriting.
And the reason for that is that
when the scroll was unrolled
and examined, it turned
out that one scribe,
I could just call it scribe
A, had written the front
and then he'd handed it
off to another scribe,
I'll call scribe
B, and the back is
in a quite distinctly
different writing.
So that's what you're
seeing here.
This is from -- The top
upper one is from the recto,
that is the front side,
and the lower one is
from the verso or the back side.
Looking at another angle
on this manuscript,
this is how it looked before
it was unrolled and preserved,
looking at it from the end
and you can see pretty clearly
how the scroll is rolled up
and you can see how delicate
and fragile this material is.
If you've probably seen a
piece of birch bark, you can,
if nobody's looking, you
can pull it off a tree
and a beautiful white
durable and very flexible
and very nice looking
material when it's new,
when you pull it off the tree.
When it's 2000 years old, it's
extremely fragile and delicate
and you can see all its
little bits falling off
of it no matter how
careful you are.
Another extra problem,
I've boxed in an example
of what we call delamination.
So actually, birch bark
consists of constituent layers.
There're usually three layers
that you can't see
when it's fresh.
You wouldn't notice.
But again, when it dries out,
those layers sometimes
pull apart
and sometimes they
completely separate.
That causes all kinds of
problems when you're trying
to reconstruct the manuscript
because you not only have the
manuscripts itself is broken
into component parts,
as you'll see,
but the component parts
are sometimes the front
and the back are completely
separated and it's not always
at all obvious where and
how they go together.
So anyway, this is what came
to the library some years ago.
And the first problem
is what to do with that.
It has to be conserved and
unrolled and here they are.
This is on the left is
Holly Krueger of the Library
of Congress and at the right is
Mark Barnard who was imported
from the British Library
as a special consultant
because he was the most
experienced person.
He had unrolled two premier
groups of similar types
of manuscripts discovered again
in the fairly recent past.
So we have really an A-team
conserving this difficult
manuscript and here's just a
detailed shot of how they do it.
In a word, very carefully.
Sorry. I'm going to wrong way.
So here you see the
implements that they use
and how they are working
together carefully.
And this is the result or at
least the preliminary result.
So this is the recto
side unreconstructed.
In other words, that's how it
actually looks and how it looks
in those facsimile images
in the back of the room,
which you can look at
later, as it came apart.
Several changes had to be made.
Particularly, there were these
three pieces, loose pieces
at the top, and you saw one
of them in the first image
and two others came apart.
And the conservators had
no way to know exactly
where they belonged
and the scroll
as it was unrolled was
placed on a sheet of glass
and when they were finished,
they put another piece of glass
on to seal it and that's a
permanent disposition of it.
But some of these
pieces are not actually
in their correct position,
particularly those
three at the top.
So I'll show you.
The next image is the
reconstructed version
and you'll see those pieces
are reversed and flipped
over like that and that.
So this is photoshopped.
All the reconstruction is
done on screen with Photoshop.
The original, as you'll
see it back there,
remains as it was unrolled.
And this is what
a typical problem.
We have these problems almost
always with birch bark scrolls.
When they get unrolled,
they don't come
out all nice and neat and clear.
You'll notice
in the reconstructed
image the wear pattern
and this is again very
typical of birch bark scrolls.
The best part is the bottom.
So you can see clearly
the farther up you go,
the worse the condition gets
and that's not the original top.
At the top, there were
some more lines missing,
apparently probably
not too many.
So this is actually,
believe it or not,
one of the best preserved
birch bark scrolls.
A lot of them were
worse than this.
But there is something missing
at the top and those spaces
between the pieces are
intentional and planned.
So they represent places where
the intermediate text was lost.
But as I said, this
is very typical.
The bottom is always
the best part.
Why? Because when they'd finish
the scroll, they would roll it
up and they'd roll it
up from the bottom.
So when it's rolled, the
bottom is on the inside
and it's protected and
the top is on the outside
and it's most subject to wear.
So it's very rare that
we actually get the top
of the manuscript.
And that causes plenty of
problems because, well,
that's one of the reasons that
I don't really know the name
of the title of the text
because in Indian books,
the title is written usually at
the end, not at the beginning.
Seems strange to Western
way of doing things
but that's the typical pattern.
So the title, the colophon
containing the title would've
been at the top of the back
and that's the part
that we don't have.
This is the verso and you can
see it's just the same thing
turned around and you
can see how they do it.
They write from the top to
the bottom and the flip it
over the long way and write
from the bottom to the top.
So that means we're missing
typically, in this case
and typically, we're missing
the beginning and the end
of the text, which are parts
that you most want to see
when you're trying to analyze
it but usually we don't have it.
So we look at similar
related texts.
We extrapolate.
We make up a title.
We do the best we can.
Now I've -- I don't
know if it's clear.
I've boxed in a portion
of the top of the verso,
at the top of the back side,
and that's going to be shown
in detail in the next slide.
So I just wanted to give you
a little bit of a closer look
at part of it relatively
well-preserved part of the text.
It's not as well
preserved as it looked
because if you look closely,
I don't know if you can see
from there, but actually
there are many little bits,
sections of the bark
that have delaminated
and they're actually misplaced.
So if you look closely,
you'll see some
of those lines are
jagged and interrupted
and that's delamination.
So this is what I'm going to
be doing tomorrow is trying
to figure out where those lose
bits actually correctly belong.
This is -- And just an
example of the text,
I'll explain a little
more later on.
But it's talking about when the
life in Buddhist cosmic time,
the lifetime of the
various buddhas,
and also it's explaining
in a kind
of punning way the
name of the Buddha.
His name is Padmottara because
he is pure like a lotus padma.
So that's a typical
rhetorical device.
So that's about the
manuscript itself.
Now I'd like to give you
a little bit of background
on the date and chronological
and historical context
of the manuscript.
So this manuscript
has been tested
by radiocarbon dating
twice in two different labs
and the results are here.
And the results are
a little disturbing
because they should be the same,
theoretically but they're not
and there's been some
discussion of that
and probably there was
some contamination.
These things were
packed in cotton wool
when they were shipped here
and that may have contaminated
and damaged the accuracy
of the test.
So there's really no way to know
which is the more accurate
result, the one in Australia,
number one, or the one
that was done in University
of Arizona, number two.
So all in all, we have the big
possible span from 206 BC to 1,
what does it say, 133 CE.
But that's not -- It's not a
major problem because it's all
in the ballpark and since then,
quite a few other manuscripts
of similar types have been
tested and they all fall
in period between first
century BC to third century AD.
And for specific reasons that
I'm not going to take the time
to explain now but
I'm pretty sure
that this manuscript is
either first century BC
or first century CE.
So we have a pretty good idea
of where we are historically.
And that fits right
in pretty well,
quite well with what
we understand
of historical circumstances
or historical context
of this manuscript.
So let's talk for a few
minutes about the ancient region
of Gandhara in the period
in question, end of BC,
beginning of CE period.
So Gandhara, I've learned from
speaking about this many places
that some people know
where Gandhara is
and a lot of people don't.
So I'll tell you in case
you're in the later category.
So this is a detailed map of
Western and Northwestern India.
And the area -- The rather
small area circled in green,
I hope you can see that
at least where it is,
is what we call Gandhara proper.
The city, you can't read it on
this map, but the modern city
that that's surrounding
is Peshawar
in Northwestern Pakistan.
So the valley, called the
Peshawar Valley or the area
of the Peshawar River, small
area, 120 miles from east
to west, is the Gandhara
and region proper
but there's also much bigger
surrounding region I call
Greater Gandhara, which
is the cultural region
which in the period in question
that I was talking about was
under the influence or
within the cultural sphere
of Gandhara itself.
The reason that happens, the
reason you get a thing called
"Greater Gandhara" is in
the period in question,
again first century BC to
second, third century AD,
Gandhara was very much a
political and cultural center,
major political and
cultural center in India
and adjoining regions as well.
In this period, there
were a series of invasions
or immigrations or movements,
whatever you want to call it,
by peoples from the north, from
Central Asia, from the west,
from Iran and from other places
as well who came into this sort
of what some historians call
the funnel that leads immigrants
and movements across
Asia into India
through particularly the Khyber
Pass that's the most famous site
in that pattern.
So these immigrants came
into India, set up a series
of kingdoms and eventually
The Great Kushan Empire
in the period in
question and they
on one hand imposed their power
but they rapidly assimilated
into an Indian cultural milieu
and the best and easiest way
to do that is to
become Buddhists
because Buddhism is open to all.
So what happened is that these
barbarian conquerors very
quickly became the great patrons
of, well, generous, wealthy
and generous patrons of Buddhist
monasteries and institutions
and that led to a great
flourishing of Buddhism
in Gandhara in the
period in question.
And this textural
material we are dealing
with is one manifestation
of that flourishing
period of Buddhism.
These foreign invaders, as they
might be called, are known to us
from the manuscripts but
also from a very large number
of physical remains, including
inscriptions recording
their donation.
So this is just one example,
a fairly typical example,
from the first century of a
reliquary dedicated by a member
of the royal family of
these Scythians or Saka,
Indo-Scythian rulers
of Northwestern India
with a beautiful
inscription around the top.
And I don't know if you can
see there are a few letters
that are in gold.
So actually originally the
whole inscription was inlaid
with gold wire and most of them
disappeared but for some reason,
two or three of the letters
still have their original gold,
sort of emblematic of the
generosity of their patronage.
So in the period that
I'm talking about,
Gandhara became a major center,
in some senses even the
major center of Buddhism
in the South Asian continent
and this had even greater
historical consequences
because we now know and it's
gradually becoming clearer how
Buddhism actually left the
motherland of India and went
into Central Asia
through Gandhara.
And we are now getting
very clear evidence of that
that Gandharan travelers went
into Central Asia,
brought Buddhism.
And from there, Buddhism spread
to China, to Korea, and Japan.
So Gandhara is really
a critical node,
not just in Indian history,
but in the entire
history of Buddhism.
The other best know
manifestation
of Gandharan Buddhism is
in its very abundant school
of sculpture and other arts.
And I find that in
general audiences,
that's what people are aware
of if they have any
acquaintance of Gandhara.
And Gandharan Buddhist
sculpture and again just
about the same period, time
period that I'm talking about,
first to third century AD,
you can see specimens of that
in most major museums
anywhere in the world,
including right here
in Washington, DC.
In the Freer Gallery,
there's this very amazing set
of four friezes illustrating
the four major events
of the Buddha's life.
So if you're not familiar,
I definitely recommend
a trip over there.
Quite worth it.
So I'll just show you
these as a local example.
So the first of the great
events is, of course,
the miraculous birth
of Buddha coming
out of the right
side of his mother.
And this is the enlightenment
Buddha in meditation and all
around him are the army of Mara
or the anti-Buddha attacking
him, trying to scare him,
trying to distract him.
And of course, they can't.
You have that sort of called
a force field around Buddha
and they're all coming at him
but there is this blanket area
where they can't penetrate.
And at the lower left is Mara
in dejection because he sees
that he's losing the battle.
And then the third is the
first sermon in the Deer Park
in Sarnath and you can see
the two deer at the bottom
of the chair and that's
the, the bottom of the seat,
that's the emblem
of this great event.
And then finally
the Parinirvana,
the final passing
away of Buddha.
So these are absolutely basic
to the biography of the Buddha.
But what might seem odd is
that the text that I'm here
to talk about, which is about
the life of the buddhas,
these are not mentioned
at all in that text
because the kind of, the
biography that I'm going
to be talking about is not
a conventional biography,
at least in modern terms.
It works quite differently
and I'll explain
that in a few minutes.
I want to add a little
more background information
on the nature of
Buddhist canons.
Buddhist canons are not like the
canons of say Islam or Judaism
where you have a single,
clearly-defined invariable
unilingual text
or corpus of text.
Buddhist canons are multiple.
They exist in different
forms, in different languages
from different parts
of the Buddhist world.
Basically, the best known
and most important
Buddhist canons are
in Pali Sanskrit,
Chinese, and Tibetan.
The Sanskrit is an
incomplete canon known
from fragmentary remains,
mostly from Central
Asia and from China.
Buddhism in a way you can
compare more to Christianity
in terms of its approach to
language and text and canon
because like Christianity,
Buddhism is a religious
tradition
that encourages translation,
again in contrast to Islam
and Judaism where if you read
the Quran or you read the Torah,
you read it in Arabic
or Hebrew, respectively,
because that's the
essence of it.
And if you translate it, it's
just some pale imitation.
That's not the idea in Buddhism.
And the Buddha was said to
have explained to his followers
in a famous passage, speak,
explain the dharma to people
in their own language.
So right from the beginning,
there was the desire,
preference for translation.
So that's relevant to
what I'm discussing here
because we now have an
increasingly large body,
several hundred manuscripts,
almost all fragmentary,
in the Gandhari language, which
I will explain in a moment.
So I am willing to go
out on a limb and say
that there was a complete
Gandhari canon in antiquity.
It disappeared until recently.
Why? Well, simply because
Gandhara ceased to be a part
of the Buddhist world
or Buddhism died
out at least 1000
years ago in Gandhara
and it was completely
forgotten until recently.
So I would make the case
that we're actually
rediscovering an unknown canon
of Buddhism and that's the
canon that has been translated
into Gandhari language.
And the Gandhari language was
in its day just the
local vernacular language
of the northwestern part
of the Indian subcontinent.
So it's linguistically
related fairly closely
to Pali and Sanskrit.
And so I just have a quickie
comparison chart for those
of you who are familiar
with or interested
in this sort of thing.
So the same verse in Gandhari,
Sanskrit and Pali and I tried
to clarify it by, I picked
one word, in boldface,
which is the word for
a man or a human being.
So you can see the relationships
of manocie [phonetic]
in Gandhari, manuoyaci
[phonetic] in Sanskrit
and manusso [phonetic]
in Pali and so forth.
You can make what
you will of that.
The Gandhari language is always
or almost always connected
with the Kharosthi script,
which looks something like this.
Kharosthi script, which is
written from right to left,
although not in this example,
is unlike the Gandhari language,
which is of Indian origin.
The Kharosthi script
is of Western,
that is Semitic origin
derived or connected
with the Aramaic script.
So this is the alphabetical
order or the character set
of Kharosthi script
but it's written
in Western way, left to right.
And that alphabet is
called Arapacana at the top.
Why Arapacana?
Well, that's why just
the first five letters.
So as we say "alphabet,"
we call it alphabet just
by citing the first two letters
of the Greek alphabet, alpha,
beta, same principle was common
in many other scripts
or language groups.
So that's the Arapacana
alphabet.
And this is a chart
which shows the,
illustrates the relationship
between the Aramaic script
and the Kharosthi script and
I just circled some examples
where it's relatively clear
the derivation and connection
with the Aramaic prototype.
It's actually a complicated
and controversial
and interesting topic but
I won't go into it here.
So that's all more or
less by way of background.
Now I'll come to the main
point, context and significance
of the Library of
Congress scroll.
What's it about?
Well, I call the
"Many Buddhas Sutra."
I would describe it
as a combined comparative
biographical summary
of the lives of 15 Buddhas
beginning with Dipankara,
who lived many billions of years
ago, and ending with Sakyamuni
or Siddharta or "our Buddha"
as he's sometimes called.
And then going on one
more to Maitreya or Ajita
who is the next Buddha.
So those 14 Buddhas in the past
and one Buddha in the future.
So these are the 15
Buddhas involved.
Start with Dipankara.
Number 14 is Sakyamuni
who actually is Sakyamuni
the second, surprisingly.
And then on to Maitreya
in the future.
But this biography is not the
kind of biography that you saw
in those four sculpted images
that I showed you before.
In fact, those four great
events, the four prime events
of the Buddha's life
are not mentioned at all
in this strange kind
of biography.
So what it is about?
Well, I've summarized
that in this chart.
There are seven points of
information which are enumerated
for each of the Buddhas.
So it starts out
with the predictions.
I'll explain the significance
of that a little bit later.
And the predictions made by each
of the 15 Buddhas and so forth.
So for example number
three, I'll show later.
The lifespan tells you how
long each Buddha lasted.
So it's not a narrative
presentation.
It's a summary of information.
And that has its own
significance, an importance,
which I'll try to
clarify as I go through.
So the next slide I'm going
to show you the specific,
the full information, I've
picked item five, social class,
the varna it's called
in Sanskrit,
which of the four classes of
society each of the Buddhas
and I picked that, I showed
that one because it's short
and I can fit it all in
one slide So if we read,
Dipankara went forth,
that means, you know,
became a Buddha approximately
from a brahman family,
Sarvabhibhu from
ksatriya family.
Padmottara was a brahman.
Atyuccagamin was
ksatriya, on and on and on.
Maybe not the most exciting
reading to the un-initiated.
This is the part that I don't
show my undergraduate students.
You can imagine their
eyes glazing over.
But it has considerable
interest and significance.
I'm not going to go into this
example here although it implies
something about the social
views of ancient Buddhism.
But I want to show another one.
This is another category,
category three
and the seven points
of information,
which is the lifespans
of the Buddha.
And I couldn't fit
in all 15 Buddhas,
so I just give approximately
the last half.
And here, you'll see
a clear progression.
Vipasyin Buddha number eight
lived for 80,000 years,
Buddha number nine 70,000
years, et cetera, et cetera,
down to number 13,
who is Kasyapa the
immediate predecessor
of the historical
Buddha Sakyamuni.
He lived for 20,000 years.
And I -- And this is Sakyamuni.
By the way, this whole
text is, of course,
being recited, told
by Sakyamuni.
He predicts that he
will live only 80 years.
So you see it's very,
it's a pronounced drastic
downward progression
in the lifetime of the Buddhas.
And this is a matter of concern
because a year in the life
of the Buddha or a day
or an hour in the life
of a Buddha is a
very precious thing.
So it gives you a sense
of the world getting
somehow deteriorating.
Well, the world is
always deteriorating
and so it always seems.
But when you look at the next
item, which is category four,
the periods, the
historic periods
in which the Buddhas lived, you
actually get a different message
or a different picture.
So here, we have -- I was
able to fit all 15 on.
So this is the historical
progression,
the sweep of history when
these earlier Buddhas lived
and when the future
Buddhas will live.
So Dipankara, which is
actually the same as Dipankara,
lived in an uncountable
eon before the present eon.
I'll try to explain
briefly Buddhist cosmology.
It's a little different than
what you might be used to.
An uncountable eon
is a technical term.
It doesn't mean you
can't count it.
It means it's so huge.
So an uncountable
eon is, I believe,
the best calculation I've
been able to find is 10
to the 154th power
number of years.
So virtually uncountable.
The next Buddha, Sarvabhibhu, 10
million eons, the third 100,000
and so forth, 1000, 500.
So you see a different
kind of progression.
You see for instance
in number nine and ten,
you have two buddhas,
Sikhin and Visvabhu,
who lived in the same
eon and then the 11th
through 15th are all in the
same eon and that's the eon
that we're living in now.
And that's called
the bhadrakalpa
because Bhadra means
good, happy, fortunate,
because it's the era in which
many buddhas are living.
So you get -- There's a kind
of balance between the decrease
in the lifetime of the buddhas,
in the lifespan of the buddhas
but they're getting more
frequent in history.
There's another related text
which contains these lists
of buddhas and their times
and their characteristics.
It's called the
Bhadrakalpikasutra.
Some of you might
be familiar with it.
And Bhadrakalpika means it talks
about the bhadrakalpa,
kalpa means eon.
And it's a list of buddhas
but not from the past
but looking ahead in the future.
So it actually starts with the
first Buddha in the bhadrakalpa
that is Kakusandha and goes
through Sakyamuni, our Buddha,
and Maitreya and then 996
more buddhas are still to come
within this Bhadra era.
So this is very important for
Buddhist practice or philosophy
or soteriology because the
point is to give encouragement
and comfort that Buddhas will
although we have missed the
Buddha, we living now, we're
not during the lifetime
of the Buddha but there
will be buddhas to come
and in future years if we
pursue the Buddhist path,
we might get the blessing
of actually some day a
million years form now
or a billion years
from now actually see
and be the presence
of the Buddha.
So there's a balance of the
downward trajectory of the world
in general but the
increasing promise
of increasing numbers
of buddhas.
Let me turn to my next topic
which is how many
buddhas are there.
So at this point, you
might be wondering the text
that I'm primarily concerned
with contains 15 buddhas.
I mentioned another one
that enumerates 1001 buddhas
and there are many
other numbers.
There's a famous early
sutra, the [inaudible] sutra,
which has seven buddhas which
seems to be the original number.
There's another polytext
called Buddhavamsa
which lists 25 buddhas.
And significantly in that
case, it lists 25 buddhas
but it begins with Dipankara
and that's particularly
an important moment
within the history of
the buddhas plural,
Dipankara has a special
importance
which I will explain
in a few minutes.
Just I'll mention one
other number, the Mahavastu
which is a Sanskrit
biography of the Buddha,
also has a list of buddhas.
It has a long list,
331,140,263 buddhas
from the remote inconceivable
past
down to the present
time of Sakyamuni.
So how many buddhas are there?
Well, let me come back to
the point about Dipankara.
Why is Dipankara
special in these lists?
Why do -- Why is he stressed
in most of them and in
at least two important cases,
including our manuscript,
it begins with him?
Well, because he's the Buddha
who produced our
Buddha Sakyamuni.
And by produced, I will try
to say he inspired the person
who would eventually be
reborn as the Buddha.
He inspired him to become a
Buddha and he actually predicted
that that being would
become a Buddha.
So let me explain.
I'll show how that happened.
Here, I've just given
you the basic list
but I've emphasized
Dipankara and Sakyamuni
because they have this
special connection.
And this is the famous
scene where it all started.
This is where a young man,
a very handsome young man
named Megha or Sumedha,
different names, in
extremely remote past,
in the time of Dipankara,
was walking down the street
and he saw the Buddha Dipankara.
And he was overcome with power
and radiance of the Buddha.
And the Buddha was walking
along the road and maybe it was
like today, the road
was wet and muddy
and he didn't want the
Buddha to get his feet dirty.
So he undid his -- He had
this beautiful long thick hair
and he threw it over
the road for the Buddha
to walk on, to keep
his feet dry.
And the Buddha seeing that said,
knew that this man
Megha was special
and had a special destiny
and predicted that he would
in the future become a Buddha
and Megha was inspired
to pursue the path.
And eventually after millions
and millions of lifetimes,
he in fact became the Buddha
and that's what we see here
in this Gandharan sculpture.
So the point is where
do buddhas come from
and how many are there?
The answer is buddhas
come from other buddhas.
A buddha predicts and produces,
inspires the attainment
of Buddhahood by another person
or by other people
in the long future.
So how many buddhas are there?
I finally come back
to the question.
Infinite number.
Why infinite?
Because time is infinite in
the Buddhas conception both
in the past and the future.
There is no beginning.
There is no end.
And throughout history, buddhas
are either present or most
of the time in the process
of forming at some time.
And that's why the Mahavastu
can say in all seriousness
that there are 331
million et cetera buddhas.
There're actually
much more than that.
There are an infinite number.
But these different texts or
these different presentations,
usually by the Buddha himself,
simply address the issue
or explain the issue in a
limited scope because you can't,
well the Buddha can talk about,
understand eternity
but we can't.
So it takes -- These different
texts are really slices
of history, slices of Buddha
history, which is infinite
from beginning to end.
Some of them talk
about the recent past.
Some of them talk about a
little farther in the past.
Some go into the future.
Some are concerned
mainly with the future.
But they're all just
pieces of the big picture.
I call them slices of history.
Let me turn to my penultimate
topic, which is to step back
and try to give you some idea
of the importance of this text
and the position of this text
within Buddhist literature
more broadly.
I think I've already
-- Excuse me.
I hope I've already made it
clear that this text is new.
It's text we've never
seen before but it's
by no means totally
unprecedented.
We have similar texts or texts
of similar theme in other parts
of the Buddhist literature and
that's why I borrowed the title
"Many Buddha Sutra,"
Bahubuddha-sutra,
from another Sanskrit book
that has a similar portion.
And that's interesting, now I'm
speaking in terms of the history
of Buddhist literature,
what this is showing us.
We find similar descriptions
of the buddhas
in other Buddhist literature.
It's Sanskrit, Pali, Chinese.
But they're usually incorporated
into much bigger text
like the Mahavastu
or the [inaudible],
these enormous multivolume
texts.
What we have here are we are
finding the actual component
parts of some of
those massive texts.
So it's beginning
to become clearer
that there was a process,
for lack of better term I
call it the clumping process,
in the history of Buddhist
literature that individual,
what were originally
individual texts have tended
to get squished together
into these sort
of encyclopedic long works.
There are other texts which
are more or less familiar.
We have for instance
Gandhari versions of texts
that were known in essentially a
similar form in other languages,
usual Pali, Sanskrit, Chinese
or combinations thereof.
So these are not new texts
but they are new versions
of previously known texts.
So it's less spectacular
but to the specialists,
it's extremely interesting
because you can do all sorts
of textual comparisons of the
details and relationships.
So, you know, to
us, it's exciting
as if someone discovered the
putative Aramaic original form
of the Gospels, New Testament
Gospels known only in Greek.
So that's a big deal for us.
And then there's a
third class of material
in this Gandhari literature
which I haven't talked about
and I don't have time to
introduce but I just wanted
to say there are texts
which are completely new
for which we have no parallel
or no approximately
similar material in any
of the other several
Buddhist literatures
and these are great eyeopeners.
They give us views, new
dimensions of Buddhist doctrine
and Buddhist literature that we
had no idea of in many cases.
So what do we have, couple
hundred scraps of partial texts
which are clearly part of
what was originally a much
larger literature.
I think Gandhari Buddhist
literature in its day,
there must've been thousands of
different texts in existence.
So it's very much tip of the
iceberg situation but, you know,
you can look at the tip and
if you look closely enough,
you can sort of extrapolate the
picture of the whole iceberg.
I have a larger vision
or fantasy
of original Indian Buddhism as
an ocean with many icebergs,
each representing the
local textual traditions
or the local canons
of the different parts
of the Indian world.
Those icebergs are mostly gone.
They've melted away.
We have a few of them.
We have the Pali canon.
We have the partial
Sanskrit canon.
But I have the feeling now that
there were many local canons.
All had a common core.
I don't mean to give the idea
they're completely different.
They had a common core but they
had many different texts in
and around that basic
commonality.
Those other Buddhist literatures
or canons most of them are gone
and I would say there's no
hope of finding them mainly
for a simple physical
reason, the climate of India,
of India proper is such
that organic materials,
manuscripts never last for
more than a few hundred years.
There are really no really old
manuscripts in India proper.
You only get the ancient
manuscripts from the borderlands
of India, in this case Gandhara
which has a more moderate
climate and more conducive
to the survival of organic
materials of manuscripts.
So extrapolating and I'm going
out on a limb a little bit.
From the tip of the Gandharan
iceberg, I try to see the shape
of the whole iceberg and from
that I try to guess the shape
of all the other icebergs
that theoretically
existed and never will.
But the details of this are
gradually become clearer as we,
myself and my colleagues
and collaborators
in this Gandharan enterprise,
work through the materials we
have and that's why I'm here.
So I just want to conclude with
a few words on specifically
on what I and my colleagues are
doing with these manuscripts.
Jonathan mentioned
already in his introduction
that I have published a
translation, really it's a kind
of preliminary translation, of
this text and it's in my book
"Buddhist Literature of Ancient
Gandhara," which is on the table
and actually obviously open
to the appropriate pages
where I translate
this whole thing.
But that's actually
just the beginning.
The translation with this sort
of material, this sort of work,
translation is not
the main part.
So what I'm working on and why
I'm here, other than of course
to speak to you, but to do some
of the detailed work
towards the production
of a complete scholarly
detailed philological edition,
that more for the specialists.
So that will eventually take the
form of one of those black books
that you see on the table there.
That's a series called
"Gandharan Buddhist Text."
So that's the academic
presentation of this material.
My other book is meant more
for the general readership.
So one of these years, I don't
dare be more specific on that,
I do commit myself that
there will be a black book
in the Gandharan Buddhist
text on this manuscript
and hopefully tomorrow I'll
begin making some progress
towards that.
But for the meantime,
you can feel free
to consult my translation and
this is the book in question.
This one already
actually exists.
So thank you for your attention.
Be glad to answer questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Jonathan Loar:
So we'll open it
up to questions if
anybody has any.
>> Richard Solomon: Please.
Yes.
>> I have a question.
Could you just say something
about how the manuscripts,
I mean how we get manuscripts,
how [inaudible] manuscripts?
>> Richard Solomon: Yes, that's
a little bit complicated.
The problem is that in nearly
all cases we don't really know
where the manuscripts come from
and that's why I
didn't talk about that.
Almost all of the manuscripts
of this type have come
up through private collections
or antiquities market
and that is frankly
a murky place.
The people who have possession
of them may or may not know
where they actually came from
and they may or may not tell you
or may or may not
tell you the truth.
But what we do know fairly
certainly is that some,
probably most, maybe all of them
were originally in clay pots
and we actually have not here
but in the British Library
we actually have one
of the clay pots
in which they came.
And these pots were buried
probably under stupas
or near stupas in a monastery.
So they put the manuscripts
in the pots,
sealed it up with a kind of,
I think probably with beeswax,
put a lid on it and sealed it,
and they buried it in the stupa.
At least some of those came
from Hadda, in Afghanistan
if you're familiar with that.
They all come --
They probably --
All of most of them come
from eastern Afghanistan,
maybe from some northwestern
Pakistan.
And so that's -- Unfortunately,
that's all we really know.
There are no cases where we
have any of these manuscripts
and know specifically definitely
exactly where they came from
but we have some general
knowledge about the provenance.
It's a problem.
Yes, please.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes. You may be referring to
in Buddhist literature they,
in [inaudible], they talk about
Taxila, which was the great city
of that area, and they
call it the university
but that's actually kind of an
anachronism and that's something
that modern scholars, modern
translators have used that term
but really it was just kind
of center of learning but not
in a formal sense
of a university.
But in terms of propagation,
well we don't know very much
about that but there's one very
important point that we do know
and that concerns what I
mentioned briefly before,
the transmission
of this material,
I mean Buddhist literature
in general,
into Central Asia
and into China.
So there's something called
the Gandhari hypothesis
which I didn't talk about
but I will for a minute
because it's relevant
to your question.
This is something that actually
goes back to I think the 1930s.
It was first noticed that
if you look at some types
of Chinese Buddhist
texts and, of course,
Chinese Buddhist texts are, the
[inaudible] are all translated
from Indian originals.
And this was a huge
enterprise that went
on from the second
century BC for, I'm sorry,
second century AD
for a thousand years.
It was this enormous project
of translating the Buddhist
scriptures into Chinese.
It's actually the biggest
and most impressive
translation project
in the history of the world.
I'll go out on a
limb and say that.
Very few people outside
Buddha circles know that
but it's a major achievement in
world civilization I would say.
Now concerning that, there was
this idea called the Gandhari
hypothesis and what happened
is that certain text scholars,
philologists were looking at
the early Chinese translations,
second, third, maybe
fourth century,
and looking at how they
rendered the Indian names.
And this was a problem
because Indian names
and Chinese names are extremely
different in the structure
of the language and the
sound system are so different
and the writing system,
everything is different,
so they struggled
with representing Buddhist
Indian names in Chinese but some
of these early scholars noted
that there were maybe oddities
in the way that the
names were presented
which made them question
what had been assumed,
which it was assumed that the
Chinese translations were made
from Sanskrit but
certain of the features
of the names actually
didn't line up with Sanskrit
but they do line up with
the corresponding Gandhari
pronunciations, like
that slide I showed you
where you'd see the
different sound systems.
So the Gandhari hypothesis
then was
that the Chinese Buddhist
texts, not all of them
but the early phase,
were actually based not
on Sanskrit originals but
on Gandhari originals.
And one of the question
marks about that theory was
at the time and for decades
afterwards there were no
Gandhari text.
Now to make a long
story short, there are
and so this new material
definitely supports,
I would say proves the
Gandhari hypothesis.
So that's really, coming back to
your question, the propagation,
the historically
important propagation is
that these were brought
by various people
into China and translated.
They probably wasn't
propagated in India proper
because in India proper,
the other regions had their
own corresponding sets of texts
in their own local
languages and dialects.
I hope I answered your question.
Yes, please.
>> Thank you very much for the
wonderful [inaudible] research.
Do you know the approximate
dimensions
of the original scrolls?
>> Richard Solomon: Oh,
I didn't mention that.
Is the facsimile
their actual size?
>> Jonathan Loar: Close.
>> Richard Solomon: Yes.
In the back, you can
look at it afterwards.
About that long.
Does that seem right?
So the original would've
been somewhat longer.
The dimensions of these
scrolls vary a lot.
This is one of the shorter ones.
Ah, yes. Thank you.
That long.
This was probably,
as far as I see,
it was made from a single
piece of birch bark.
But, of course, you're
limited by the size of --
So there are -- We have
some much longer scrolls,
some that are several
yards long but,
of course, they're put together.
We call them composite scrolls.
They're sheets of bark, you
know, typically not longer
than this but there might be 10
or 15 or even more put together.
I'm having some doubts because
there's a, you can't see it
from there, but there's
a blank strip here
and I wonder whether
that's actually a juncture
and whether this was
made, put together
from two separate pieces.
So that's -- I'm going to
be checking that tomorrow.
The range, very wide range.
There are some -- The smallest
ones are about this high.
The longest ones are
yards and yards long.
Yes, please.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
I'm sorry.
I'm not hearing.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Oh, yes. That's -- I've
wondered about that.
I'm not sure I understand it.
In the list of 15,
there's Sakyamuni the first
and of course it
doesn't say the first.
I just put together
those numbers.
He was number eight.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
And then Sakyamuni the second.
But there's another point about
that which I didn't mention.
I talked about that
list in the Mahavastu
of 331,140,263 buddhas.
What I didn't say is that out of
the 300 million, out of the 331,
300 million were
named Sakyamuni.
And according to that
text, there was a stretch
of 30 million buddhas in a row
that were all had the same name.
And I have thought about and
failed to understand what that,
why that is and what that means.
But there is -- You know,
buddhas are and by impression,
they're more or less the
same and their images,
I don't think I have one
here, but you see in Gandhari
and other sculptures,
you see sets of buddhas
like the seven buddhas or
sometimes eight buddhas
and they're all almost
exactly the same.
So there seems to be a
range of possibilities
that buddhas are always similar
and they can be very similar
and sometimes they are
absolutely identical.
But I'm still pondering that.
It is hard to understand that.
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Yes. It's hard to
give exact numbers.
Let me explain the problem.
There are groups of manuscripts.
There are six or
seven major groups.
And typically, one of these
groups will typically have,
take two or three
dozen manuscripts
but there's one group
which comes
from a place called Bamiyan,
which people have heard
of because they were, everybody
knows they were giant buddhas
and the Taliban blew them up
in 1999 or whenever it was.
What the public general
doesn't know is
that they were also
thousands and thousands
of manuscripts found there.
And most of those manuscripts
were later manuscripts
in Sanskrit but there's
an early phase
of Gandhari manuscripts similar
to what I've been talking about.
Now that contains -- That
consists of 300 or so fragments
and most of them are -- When I
say fragments, I mean like this.
So it's very hard to
say, okay, what is that?
Is that 300 manuscripts
or are they part
and how many manuscripts
were they actually parts of
and in most cases they're
so small that's it's
hard to be sure.
So there might be 300 fragments
but there might've been 50
or 60 manuscripts at a
little more than a guess.
So that's why the
numbers are very fuzzy
and that's why I've
been a little bit vague.
But I would say we have
-- Well, I said 200 --
We have partial remnants
of at least 200 manuscripts
and we have possibly
more than that.
In terms of complete manuscripts
or texts that are complete
or more or less complete,
you know, say 90%,
very few, maybe three or four.
This thing, I think I actually
calculated, I don't remember.
We have maybe 75 to 80%
of the original of this
and that's much, much
better than usual.
So it's a little hard to
say exactly how much we have
but we do have a lot of
material, enough to really begin
to get a glimpse
of the big picture.
Yes, please.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
The answer is almost
all are Buddhist texts,
not necessarily sutras
but Buddhist texts
of any kind clearly
Buddhist content.
Sorry, I broke your microphone.
There are two exceptions
in all of these 200
or whatever manuscripts,
there are two exceptions
but they're really interesting.
One of them is a kind
of legal document.
The other, which was just
discovered very recently and is
about to be published
by my colleague Mark
Allen [assumed spelling],
you might know who he is.
And it's actually
just little fragments
of what would've been a very
interesting text but it's enough
to see what's going on.
It's actually a record of the
monastery's record of donations.
And not only that, it lists
the names of the donors
and the primary donor
was [inaudible],
who's a well-known figure in
Indian history of around 100 AD.
So this is really a great thing
for us because it clarifies
and confirms the historical
context within that period
that I talked about, that
so-called foreign ruler period,
and he was previously known but
[inaudible] his relationship
to Buddhism was not
clear and now we have it.
He was mentioned several
times in this text.
So it's not a Buddhist text in
the sense that the others are
but it's monastic business
and it's a real eyeopener.
And this is going to be
published in a few months.
So really change the picture.
But that's all we have
so far of that type.
>> Jonathan Loar: I
think we have time
for maybe one more question.
Are there any burning questions?
Otherwise, we'll be here
around the reading room
for [inaudible] afterwards but
I feel incredibly fortunate
to be learning so
much about the scroll.
Thank you so much, Dr. Solomon.
>> Richard Solomon: My pleasure.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And thanks again to everybody
for braving the rain and wind.